Richie sunax says we're facing a
profound economic crisis but what does
that actually mean is it really profound
well let's have a look at some of the
numbers starting with this this is
giving you a sense of whether we might
well be contracting uh or expanding if
anything is in the blue area we are kind
of getting bigger as an economy if it's
in the red area we are Contracting it's
basically a recession warning you can
see the UK's line going down into that
recession territory but here's the
Striking thing it's not just the UK it's
other countries as well a lot of the
Eurozone for instance the US they're all
basically the same shape so you know do
they have profound economic crises as
well perhaps they do but it's not just
us we're not alone and also there are
issues that are going deeper they're
going into household Pockets right now
mortgages for instance are getting much
more expensive because of higher
interest rates right now if you're
taking out a two-year fixed rate
mortgage you're paying potentially the
highest amount as a percentage of your
income that we've seen since the late
1980s that's a mortgage burden the
higher that is the bigger the squeeze
and the same thing again for energy okay
so this is Energy prices those bills and
even after the energy price guarantee
we're still talking about the biggest
squeeze on energy spending that we've
seen essentially ever that goes back to
the 1950s so these two things add up and
they mean as a result we are getting
less well off as a nation our Collective
standard of living our ability to pay
our net worth is going down and you get
a sense of that with this chart this is
a kind of a measure of that Collective
net worth versus how much what we
typically tend to spend our money on and
have a look at how that has gone down
that is the impact of higher energy
prices mean we are basically poorer as a
nation and you know it's not just that
that we've been focusing on recently is
it it's also growth and this shows you
productivity one of the best measures of
growth output per hour up until the
financial crisis it was Rising rising
Rising but look at what happened since
it essentially flatlines so many of our
problems at the moment come back to that
chart and no prime minister recently has
been able to deal with it uh absolutely
no Chancellor either so I should say and
look at this 10-year bondier now this is
one of the charts we've looked at quite
a lot recently this is kind of what's
going on in markets what's it kind of
defined Liz truss's time in office that
went up very sharply indeed but two
things to note first of all it was
starting to rise before Liz truss came
into office so that predated her time
now you can't blame it all on her and
it's starting to come down in the last
few weeks that suggests that could help
Richie see that when it comes to paying
off the Bills second bit of good news
this is wholesale gas prices and again
you can see they've been very volatile
going up to very high levels recently
but look at what's happened in the last
few weeks they have come down down to 35
p a thumb so some good news there things
could be a little bit better than many
people had expected that doesn't mean
we're not facing an economic crisis but
perhaps it means that this man is very
keen to underline there's some tough
news and maybe tough spending cuts to
come